it's not every day that Sicilian
anti-mafia police are congratulated on
the streets of Palermo
but they've just arrested Italy's most
Wanted mafia boss Matteo Masini De Niro
who's been on the run for 30 years the
man reported to have once boasted that
he could fill a cemetery with his
victims didn't resist
[Music]
it was a major pre-planned operation and
at least one other arrest was made the
police and prosecutors are now
celebrating congratulated by Italy's
Prime Minister Giorgio Maloney the
police had accused messini De Niro of
bombings on the Italian Mainland that
killed 10 people
the prime minister went on to pay her
respect to murder judges including one
of Masini De Niro's victims Giovanni
Falcone
[Music]
it's a day of celebration for
respectable people and it's a day of
celebration for the relatives of the
victims of organized crime because the
sacrifices of so many Heroes was not in
vain because some others took over their
legacy and the war has been carried on
right now Messina De Niro doesn't look
like The Godfather but the 60 year old
is seen as the last in a line of old
school senior figures to have either
died or been arrested in the kosa Nostra
that's the Sicilian crime syndicate
portrayed in The Godfather movie
was the youngest member of a leadership
group within the Sicilian Matthew that
took control of the Sicilian Mafia in
the early 1980s essentially behind
massacring all their Rivals and then
mounted a major attack on the Italian
State now the question is whether
Messina De Niro will reveal any of his
many Secrets among them the names of
politicians suspected of conniving with
the mafia Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera